Hey guys,
You know, there's a huge attack on what it means
to be a man in the day and
age that we live in today.
And when we read through the Bible, for me,
there's one man that stands out from most of them.
And that is David.
Because God said
that he is a man after His own heart.
And so, how do we become true men of God?
Living with the challenges that we face every
day, learning how to pursue the right things?
And above all, to really pursue God?
To have a deep relationship with Him?
That is why I wrote my new
book called Bold Pursuit.
When you have some time, check it out.
And it's going to surprise you.
I love you guys and I'll
see you in the next video.
Bye.